Joe Biden making an unannounced visit to
Ukraine and meeting with President
zielinski as China gears up to test the
president in a major way it's been
almost one year since Putin's brutal
Invasion Biden committing an additional
one-half billion dollars in assistance
and promising that the U.S will stand by
the country
I'm here to show our unwavering support
for the nation's Independence
through sovereignty and and territorial
Integrity we know that there'll be very
difficult days and weeks and years ahead
but Russia's aim was to wipe Ukraine off
the map
Putin's war of Conquest is failing
Russia's military has lost half its
territory it once occupied
the trip comes amid growing fears that
China could soon be helping Putin out in
the war Secretary of State Anthony
blinken offering up this warning
China has been engaged in providing
rhetorical political diplomatic support
to Russia but we have information that
gives us concern that they are
considering providing lethal support to
Russia in uh in the war against Ukraine
and it was important for me to share
very clearly with with Wang Yi that this
would be a serious problem
the stakes of the war are also growing
after Kamala Harris accused Russia of
crimes against humanity the United
States has formally determined
that Russia has committed
crimes against humanity
and I say
to all those who have perpetrated these
crimes
and to their superiors
who are complicit in these crimes
you will be held
to account
I'm not even going to go to Pamela first
all right let me go to you first saying
let's talk about what blinken said to
his counterpart uh Wang Yi he said about
the surveillance balloon that it was
violation of our sovereignty
international law and it won't be
tolerated again but more importantly uh
he basically said if China supports
lethal uh weapons to Russia they're in
for a problem do you think Russia's uh
China is scared
scared I don't know but thinking about
it probably and actually if you go back
to the beginning of when Russia invaded
Ukraine remember they Russia thought
that the Chinese were going to be their
best friends and the Chinese have given
them the cold shoulder over the past
year they have provided things like
helmets uh things that were non-lethal
weapons which the West has sort of said
okay that we're gonna we'll let that
slide but one step more and there's
going to be a big problem and I admire
the president for going today I I think
that the deliverables are just more of
the same it's more money and
more ammo and more tanks but no I'm
sorry no tanks and no planes and I do
feel like for since the beginning that
we committed to helping them once we saw
that they were willing to fight for
themselves
NATO rallied together I think the
president deserves some credit for that
but they are all NATO is also scared so
they're like we got to do something we
got to Pony up we got to pay more we got
to be a part of this but now it feels as
if we continue to provide the Ukraine
sorry Ukraine with what they need slowly
rather than in terms in order to get
ahead of it and once a conflict has gone
past six months it's very hard to get
people to then come to the table and say
let's all try to work this out because
now the hatred gets ingrained there are
a lot of casualties uh on the on
civilian casualties on the Ukraine side
and then so many Russians have also been
killed on the battlefield one of the
things I listened to today was the call
me back podcast and Neil Ferguson was on
talking about this Cold War II concept
and we're entering a presidential
election season we'll be very
interesting to see how everybody handles
it going forward and I think that the
Biden Administration has taken the
Americans support for Ukraine a little
bit for granted because they don't
constantly remind you why it's in the
National interest and you're looking at
a situation where the Ukraine Russia War
continues and maybe goes to points
Beyond that's Russia's goal or at least
state of goal
um Israel is going to is not going to
put up with Iran having a nuclear weapon
if you read today they're closer than
ever and then the possibility of China
invading in Taiwan so that's a lot of
hot spots not to mention our Southern
border and all points South well you
know will the the longer the war goes on
and I've listened to generals talk about
the fact that this war can go on for
several more years I mean you have to
Wonder
Isn't it important that if Russia is not
at its fighting Peak which it obviously
is not uh and with the good weather
coming isn't it time for us now to you
know if we're going to support support
now get in and get out you can't have
this during an election or at least
Biden can't and you also you have to hit
Russia they don't seem as strong as they
suggest they are well I think the
historical record of Russia whether or
not it be World War One or World War II
is to endure Grievous losses for the
first year or two of a campaign and to
win eventually through attrition throw
bodies at their problem and eventually
win the war
I think my concern is a little bit at a
deeper level and I think President Biden
visiting Ukraine today is somewhat
symbolic of my concerns it's a national
holiday the United States of America
it's President's Day and he's visiting
the president of Ukraine it's as though
we don't have our own problems Dana
mentioned the southern border of course
there's what's going on in Ohio but
those aren't just political talking
points to say where's Joe Biden's
priorities it's this if this is your
highest priority then it should be a
priority for you I think to articulate
an exit strategy what is the end of this
because when you talk about those hot
spots Dan I've seen others Emmanuel Todd
was a French intellectual last week that
says we're now in essentially on the
path to World War III it's an economic
War that's divided itself into East and
West China and Russia are aligned
economically and economic Wars lead to
kinetic Wars you know trade Wars lead to
bombs and so I would ask the president
if this is your highest priority and you
visit Ukraine on President's Day what is
your exit ramp to avoid World War III
okay good question Greg what is well we
we've been talking about this for a year
uh none of the information coming from
Russia or Ukraine is reliable
so you know we're in we're in a
consistent persistent fog of War yet
it's amazing how easy we adapted to this
for a year I mean it was like for a
while we were outraged we have to be
honest this war is background noise to
us we've got many distractions all these
things going on in that way they're very
lucky in the sense we aren't fighting
over the money and for Joe this is an
easy cause uh to attach himself to
because the suffering is intangible or
immediate these are other people dying
if you look at Ukraine they can fight
forever because we're just going to give
them the technology and the Russians are
going to keep throwing bodies at it this
this is going to go on forever and it
doesn't seem to be any desire for
negotiation and that makes me wonder why
it's like people are making money off
this that aren't dying so it's good for
them and and uh it's just I don't know I
haven't changed my opinion about this
since day one so I I just can't believe
it's a year and I'm still saying the
same old crap you know Jessica yeah
Americans certainly do have the right to
ask questions or over 30 billion in the
whole
um but should there be Congressional
oversight you know Ukraine is known for
corruption I mean shouldn't we at least
have some sense of where the money's
going
I think that they do tell you at least
like this is what this cost we're
sending 28 tanks that's the cost of this
some degree of oversight for sure but
zielinski president zielinski is not
known for corruption prior presidents
have been I know that he's relatively
new to the job but I don't see many
people saying you know I think that
they're taking the cash and running or
he's going out and you know drinking and
going to the casino it seems like it's
being spent on a war and now that we
have you know the crimes against
humanity terminology which has legal
repercussions a very serious action that
Kamala Harris took and I think it is
important that they pulled it off as the
one-two punch right she went first she's
at the Munich security conference and
that's a big deal that's something that
you would typically think the president
would be doing but he made sure that it
was Kamala Harris that was the one that
said that he could have said it today
he's known since Friday that he was
going to Kiev to see president zolinski
today so some degree of oversight for
sure but I think it is interesting that
Mitch McConnell gave an interview a
couple days ago where he said this is
the most important issue and we need to
be taught talking about it more and
telling the American public why it is
that we should be in this fight and if
you have Unity from President Biden and
Mitch McConnell on this maybe people
will get more answers about it because I
think when you do struggle you don't say
I don't want to help ukrainians you do
Wonder okay I'm here and I'm paying
taxes and I want to make sure that I'm
supported at least as well as they are
do you guys ever though wonder when
you're listening to the news when one
week you're listening to it and it's
like Ukraine is on the verge of winning
and Russia looks terrible and then the
next week it's like Russia just
completely annihilated Ukraine and then
that goes on for a week and I feel like
we're being played to keep like going
okay it's Ukraine this time so wait it
out now it's Rush it's like this could
go on forever as long as they keep
manipulating the news
Brokers are saying that that this will
be years right after the first few
months how long do we fund it I mean
we're done giving money
in Palestine that's the thing is we we
put our finger in this plug and if we
pull it out that it all goes to hell now
it's now Ukraine's future is on us
Jessica brought up Carmel Harris is
breaking this full circle I dare you to
read that tease in the pace of Kamala
Harris
I cannot I will not replicate anything
she does I want to Brian kill Mead I
want you to do me a favor I want you to
click to subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube page this is the only way that I
know for sure that you're not going to
miss any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on Fox you can get it all here on
YouTube so subscribe right now